here we go [__] up this Monday
afternoon cenotes by the Leia's true
[__] playas oh [__] I got the chronic
by the tree oh yeah that's Harvey's
favorite song I love it when you call me
big oh [__] I just creep up from behind
and ask you what your Prince's luck
who you be with what numbers sit down
let me get the meal Monday [__] I
told you you thought you wouldn't see me
for a few days take your ass to the hoop
Jack we got the bong a debt t-bone steak
cheese and Welsh is great for a few cuz
in a few we gonna do what we came to do
you know what we came to do [__]
to see the devil
I love it when you call me big pot bucks
here we go [__] it's a beautiful
day to be alive thank the Lord for
giving you another day this go up then
impose your will on these [__]
you sling a little dick here we go
baby bear baby bear oh [__]
imagine and it feels stupendous [__] a
dollar and a dream what one of the
greatest [__] albums of all time
the first biggie smalls ready to die as
real as can be you know what this is
[__] no not a black goose tooth
you know this is this is a piece of the
bong this was a piece of THC that was
stuck in the [__] bong I'm gonna
break it in half right here look at this
oh [__] keep banging there we go I love
it when you call me big papa
when you find something like this in
your book I can sell this for 80 bucks
right now this is six months of abuse
I'm saying this is like [__] what's
wrong what's Ronda Rousey's boyfriend
there's like Travis Brown's old
girlfriend right here oh [__] check it
out
[Music]
biggie smalls Junior MAFIA represent
baby baby oh oh yeah laughs a little
chunk will do right then the bong of
duty look at that that's prison style
right there
it won't even [__] fall off my finger
here we go you ready little respect
[__] oh [__]
break out the holy water oh [__] don't
worry about nothing all I know is I'm
sweaty I'm saying you do a banger than
you're sweating you're on your way
what Tanqueray Hennessey until I call
Earl what reading Lee this is it who's
ready for a blood [__] bath in lease
find he's tip-top Magoo we did a little
test run on the bond with the little
mule I'm seeing my debt and I ain't even
took my first step
[Music]
do you think you're dealing with one of
your little [__] Momo friends at the
[__] no shake shop here we go if
you're under 18 hang up now I want red
shirt just in case that bleep we don't
we keep doing that is it clock hit it
hit it don't fit the name it is nice
clock
oh [__] slow motion look at them I told
you I know how to fix alone [__] the
doctor the doctor ain't got dick on
uncle Joey if I can't fix your lung
nobody can fix you up some a right this
bong it's not hitting correctly we might
have to [__] a little mule it the
little mule was perfectly something
right with this bong this [__]
grenade of death
[Music]
what that's the one that's the one and
you thought it was gonna be a ho-hum
afternoon [__] that
go raid the [__] druggie cabinet your
uncle's got something they're [__]
ready Lee that would sit let's like get
the rock thrown are you by chemically
dizzy not nap there we go maybe watch
this [__] pong at that
here we go dog let's do this [__] here
we go what did Italy in Italy
suck suck suck suck suck suck there you
go there you go keep doing nothing
[Music]
no edible for today how to respect me
too if I'm the meat through movement
no edibles today
that's the one that's the one doctor
that's a [__] something's not right
you're playing games like I'm gonna have
to break up the little meal on fire
[__] you think you're dealing with you
don't forget sign up now uncle Joey's
bong at camp we're gonna he's already
making noises anyway youtube.com slash c
/ Joey Diaz the place to be five five
[__] minutes tip top Magoo no
[__] youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz
alright I'll see you there
stay black don't forget I love you yo
Denver in two weeks plus the birthday
show at the Ice House February 17 7:30
stage 2 just us alright stay black